what's up guys how's it going so I took
yesterday off for making a video just to
collect my thoughts and regain my energy
to to live I shot a bunch of cooking
videos today for you guys for the
holidays and I'm extremely excited about
it but what I've also extremely excited
about is what is in front of me in front
of me are some new amiibo a lot of
people at this point I don't think are
as into amiibo as they were at the
beginning but those who are into the
amiibo are really into them there's also
the casual amiibo fans so there's tons
of uses for amiibo I guess maybe tons is
sort of a little bit far stretched but
there are as I'm okay I keep saying a
ton so there's a lot of uses for amiibo
in games to sort of enhance the gameplay
on now characters so for example if you
want this is one of my absolute favorite
like this is just the coolest ever the
boo amiibo so you can bring boo to the
party with a special in-game item this
is an ebow in Mario Party suppression
this dog is so nuts oh my gosh
that's so dangerous you're gonna fall
and hurt yourself so I thought that I've
been feeling a little bit down the past
day or so oh my goodness I love that
these things make me so happy I do plan
on doing a full amiibo collection video
what I wanted to wait until I got so the
latest ones that are out that's my
sweater
that's my nice sweater and bye nice
sweater I mean I paid for this sweater
to have holes in it he thinks it's a rag
it's not a rag it's a very expensive
sweater that has holes in it the first
one that we're going to unbox is
Rosalina basically if I'm not going to
speech I'm gonna be Rosalina I think
she's just the best it's pretty great do
you like Rosalina do you want her to be
your mom does she look like your mom
does she look like your mom
I think he just puked in his mouth next
up is waluigi oh he looks so funny look
at him Wow Luigi
he looks good look at waluigi i don't
even see the dog just sitting here like
it's just sitting waiting wishing ah
Daisy Daisy was always my sister Jenna
so when we had the same tender 3d asses
I have little stickers and she was the
Daisy sticker I was peach I'm sure you
can find a picture on Instagram
somewhere this one is the best ever this
is the boo amiibo the best part about
this one is it glows in the dark
I don't think there's any other amiibo
the close my dark at least currently
this is so it's absolutely beautiful
confirmed glow in the dark
here's Wario I'm so excited for the
tennis which I think a lot of you
expecting me to make a video which I
actually did mean to make a video but
for some reason I didn't I was busy when
their announcement was happening I think
I was traveling I am excited about it
because it basically encompasses all
things home gaming but also mobile
gaming
it also has so many different
possibilities to basically take this
thing to your friend's house and also
play with them with it it's like the Wii
U and the Nintendo 3ds sort of
all-in-one with an iPad thrown in the
mix either way here's Wario Eddie calm I
forgot I was filming a video and I just
sat on my phone for however long and it
was riding back to emails I do a lot of
work just sitting on the floor this is
on last of the collection look at you
you're so big and strong just how I like
my knee bow
look at them so we're gonna see if boo
actually does glow in the dark let's
turn off all the lights
oh yes he dies let's see if we can
charge him up real good sketch you
ultimate glowing power
oh yeah he's he's glowing good he's
pretty cool let's turn our lights back
on I love technology well you guys so
much for watching this is just a fun
little amiibo unboxing video I am so
excited for a bunch of fun DS games
coming up we have Pokemon Sun and Moon
which is coming up very very soon which
will be perfect timing for you guys to
play it over the Thanksgiving break and
then even more exciting especially for
me because I love this game on wii u
Super Mario maker 40s it's going to be
incredible there's also an animal
crossing new leaf update that I haven't
actually got a chance to play it but I
did do the update so that's on my to do
this to play as well multi guys my next
video until I've got for you today just
my little baby me bows right it makes me
very upset
I'm packing my voting bag I need to have
some snacks in case the lines are long
I'm mostly upset because I feel like
this election has turned into just one
huge joke it is just one candidate
bullying the other the other bullying
the other one that's like the opposite
Oh